bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de parlement hebdo compagnie de
michaël szames us bonjour me cale on va
faire donc le tour de l'actualité
politique et parlementaire de la semaine
avec bien sûr la première conférence de
presse de françois hollande ni virage ni
tournant le président affirme simplement
maintenir le cap
se posant en président responsable at il
réussi son grand oral c'est ce que nous
allons voir le sénat a décidément joue
les trouble-fête les communistes ont
voté contre le plfss
le projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale résultat le texte est
rejeté les communistes qui votent avec
la droite c'est la troisième fois en
amour l'assemblée à bois avant le
dernier mot cela commence à faire
désordre
enfin l'opération réussie du maire
socialiste de sevran sept jours et six
nuits de grève de la faim sous la tente
devant l'assemblée stéphane gatignon a
fini par obtenir les 5 millions il
réclamait pour sa ville surendettée
il a repris la tente ce jeudi reviendra
sur cette semaine qui a pris les allures
d'un joli coup médiatique est avec nous
pour commenter toute cette actualité
cette semaine sergio coronado bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes député des
français de l'étranger pour le groupe
écologie les verts ici à l'assemblée luc
d'amérique latine dont vous êtes
originaire vous êtes né au chili puis
vous avez grandi en argentine vous êtes
élu depuis le mois de juin dernier vous
allez nous dire comment ça se passe eh
bien depuis ces quelques mois à
l'assemblée nationale mais on vous
connaît aussi en politique parce que
vous avez été le porte parole d'eva joly
lors de la dernière campagne des
élections présidentielles
mais tout d'abord je vous propose
d'écouter ce petit micro-trottoir que
nous avons fait à l'assemblée nationale
pour voir ce que vous pensent les
députés de vos premiers pas ici à
l'assemblée alors sergio coronado député
député vert
là je vais vous allez me prendre en
défaut bon j'ai déjà un petit bout de la
réponse mais abou très très petit pas du
tout j'ai pas dis c'est oui bien
évidemment je connais sergio
c'est un de mes collègues c'est
quelqu'un qui est très présent dans
l'hémicycle ça fait partie de ces
parlementaires que je ne connais pas
bien mais avec qui j'ai plaisir à
échanger mais qui ne connaît pas sergio
coronado d'autant qu'on peut aussi le
comprendre quelques fois avec son frère
qui est aussi militant un député donc
qui est qui représente des français de
l'étranger
il a vécu pendant un certain temps au
brésil ils représentent globalement les
français de l'étranger en amérique du
sud
ça a toujours été un grand voyageur faut
être polyglotte il les polyglottes faut
être en capacité de s'adapter mais c'est
quelqu'un qui a une grande capacité
d'adaptation
je vais surtout connu lors d'un débat à
la télévision avant les élections
législatives lorsqu'il était candidat
et nous avions échangé des arguments je
l'avais trouvée à la fois réactif mais
relativement bloqué excessif dans ses
prises de position politique très sympa
voie d'eau très sympa disent les députés
va concrètement pouvez nous expliquer ce
que vous faites en tant que député des
français de l'étranger c'est un petit
peu l'eau atteint peut-être pour de
l'étranger c'est un député comme les
autres ils légifèrent il est présent
dans l'hémicycle il participe aux
commissions il est nouveau c'est tout à
fait nouveau en fait c'est la réforme de
2009 qui a permis la création de 11
postes de députés des français de
l'étranger il y avait une représentation
déjà en fête
ancienne puisque les français de
l'étranger bénéficier au sénat de 12
représentants
et puis il ya également l'assemblée des
français de l'étranger mais cette
représentation était un peu bancal
puisque à l'assemblée les français qui
habitent à l'extérieur de l'hexagone
n'avait pas de député à tout à fait un
député comme les autres quand même parce
que vous vous retournez pas tous les
week-ends à votre circonscription suis
pas retournée combien de fois depuis
vous êtes député six fois ce qui est
quand même pas mal c'est ce que j'essaye
de faire en fait c'est à peu près toutes
les trois semaines de consacrer 10 jours
à ma circonscription il est évident que
je ne peux pas y retourner tous les
week-ends c'est des voyages de plus de
dix heures
je représente 33 pays d'amérique latine
et des caraïbes du mexique jusqu'en
patagonie argentine et donc on girotto
on ne peut pas être partout mais je
cible et en même temps on a aussi des
concentrations de populations de
communauté française en fait dans les
grandes métropoles que ce soit au brésil
ou à buenos aires et donc quand j'y vais
je tient des permanences je rencontre la
communauté française dans le cadre des
activités traditionnelles
je rencontre également les personnels en
poste les ambassadeurs et les consuls et
puis également une activité associative
à l'étranger les français s'organisent
il ya les accueille et à les
associations d'entr'aide et donc c'est
avec elle